JUST GO EAT IT AND ENJOY IT,
TUCKER.
>> I WILL TEXT YOU TONIGHT,
THANK YOU, SEAN.
>> Sean: WELCOME TO "TUCKER
CARLSON TONIGHT" WOW
>> Hannity: THE DEMOCRATIC A
DUMPSTER FIRE FILLED WITH
HYPOCRITICAL FAR LEFT CANDIDATES
HYPOCRITICAL FAR LEFT CANDIDATEW
HYPOCRITICAL FAR LEFT CANDIDATEL
HYPOCRITICAL FAR LEFT CANDIDATEI
HYPOCRITICAL FAR LEFT CANDIDATEG
HYPOCRITICAL FAR LEFT CANDIDATET
HYPOCRITICAL FAR LEFT CANDIDATEO
HYPOCRITICAL FAR LEFT CANDIDATED
HYPOCRITICAL FAR LEFT CANDIDATEA
SAY ANYTHING FOR POWER COMING UP
TONIGHT, FULL COVERAGE OF THIS,
WELL FRANKLY VERY DISTURBING
POLITICIANS INCLUDING ONE
UNHINGED CANDIDATE AND YOU CAN
GUESS WHO IT IS WHO IS READY TO
LOCK UP AMERICAN GUN OWNERS IF
THEY DO NOT TURN THEIR WEAPONS
OVER TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
BUT FIRST LET'S TURN OUR
ATTENTION TO A VERY IMPORTANT
ENTITY WATCH THE INVESTIGATORS
THE TIDE IS TURNING
DRAMATICALLY.
AFTER THURSDAY OF THIS WEEK, THE
HATE TRUMPED MEDIUM MOB, THE
DEMOCRATIC ALLIES FOR OVER TWO
WHEN I HAVE HERE, HAVE BEEN
PUSHING TIN FOIL HAT CONSPIRACY
THEORIES AND OUTRIGHT LIES ABOUT
COLLUSION.
THEY DON'T KNOW IT YET, BUT IT
IS DONE.
IT IS OVER.
IT IS FINISHED.
NO COLLUSION, NO OBSTRUCTION.
YELLOW A FEW TO CLING TO
SENTENCES FOR MORE LIES, MORE
FAKE NEWS, MORE FAKE LEGAL
ANALYSIS BUT IN THE END, THEY
ARE FOREVER EXPOSED FOR THE
LAYERS AND PARTISAN HACKS THAT
THEY ARE.
THEY HAVE PUT THIS COUNTRY IN
DANGER.
THE CONSTITUTION DANGER.
ON THURSDAY, THE EULER REPORT
RELEASED BY ATTORNEY GENERAL
BARR AND WITH ONLY MINOR
LEGAL REDUCTIONS AND IT WILL BE
WHAT IS THE FINAL NAIL IN THE
COFFIN TO THE CREDIBILITY OF
AMERICA'S BIGGEST RUSSIA
COLLUSION CONSPIRACY THEORIST.
IT IS OVER.
THEY DON'T KNOW IT YET.
THAT INCLUDES SO-CALLED
REPORTERS OF
"THE WASHINGTON POST" IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
THEY ACTUALLY WON A PULITZER
PRIZE IN 2018 FOR PERPETRATING A
HOAX.
THAT PRICE FRANKLY SHOULD BE
REVOKED.
I THINK IT SHOULD BE REWARDED TO
THE REAL JOURNALIST FROM A REAL
INVESTIGATIVE REPORTERS WE HAVE
EVER NIGHT ON THE SHOW AND ON
THE RADIO SHOW.
THE PEOPLE THAT WRITE THE ENTIRE
TIME BUT ALL ALONG EXPOSING
LAYER BY LAYER EVERY SINGLE
ISSUE INVOLVING WHAT IS THE
BIGGEST ABUSE OF POWER
CORRUPTION SCANDAL IN THE
HISTORY.
THE ONLY DIFFERENCES, THEY HAVE
REAL EVIDENCE THAT HAS BEEN
REPORTED OVER THE COURSE OF TWO
YEARS ON HIS SHOW.
UNLIKE SO MANY IN THE MEDIA MOB,
WE ARE NOT BLINDED BY HATE.
WE FOLLOW THE TRUTH.
THE EVIDENCE, DUE PROCESS.
SADLY THE SAME CANNOT BE SAID
ABOUT THE MEDIA MOB.
HOW THEY REPORTED ANTI-TRUMPED
GARBAGE, LIES, PROPAGANDA OVER
AND OVER AGAIN WITH ANONYMOUS
SOURCES AND OF COURSE, JUST
DOING THE DEMOCRATS FITTING.
TIGHT AT THE HIP MANUFACTURE
PRICES AND ON THURSDAY, THEY
WILL DO IT PREDICTABLY ONE LAST
TIME WITH ALL THE PHONY, LYING
OUTRAGE THEY WILL BE ABLE TO
MANUFACTURE.
THEY WANT TO BLUDGEON
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHICH HAS BEEN
THEIR GOAL ALL ALONG BY ANY AND
ALL MEANS NECESSARY.
THEY HAVE ONLY ONE DAY LEFT.
BY THE WAY, JUST BREAKING
MOMENTS AGO SARA CARTER
REPORTING THAT THREE OF THOSE
DEMOCRATS CONGRESSMAN ELIJAH
CUMMINGS, MAXINE WATERS AND
COWARDLY ADAM SHIP ACTUALLY
SIGNED A SECRET PACT BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS VOWING TO
TARGET PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
SUBPOENA ALL OF HIS FINANCIAL
AND
AN END BANKINGRECORDS BY THE WAY
AN END BANKINGRECORDS BY THE WAM
AN END BANKINGRECORDS BY THE WAR
AN END BANKINGRECORDS BY THE WAE
AN END BANKINGRECORDS BY THE WAI
AN END BANKINGRECORDS BY THE WAC
AN END BANKINGRECORDS BY THE WAE
THEY NEED TO MOVE ON FROM
COLLUSION.
THIS LETTER OBTAINED BY SARA
CARTER FROM JIM JORDAN AND NOW
RAISING SERIOUS CONCERNS OVER
THIS SECRET AGREEMENT TO TAKE
DOWN A PRESIDENT.
ACCORDING TO CONGRESSIONAL
SOURCE "THIS IS NOT HOW
COMMITTEES NORMALLY OPERATE.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE NOT INTERESTED
IN LEGISLATING BUT ATTACKING THE
PRESIDENT."
SARA CARTER TO GIVE US THE FULL
REPORT.
THAT IS WITH THE PRESIDENT IS UP
AGAINST AND HAS BEEN UP AGAINST
FROM DAY ONE.
NOW, IF THE PRESIDENT JOINED AND
GAVE $5 MILLION AND THEIR
AGENDA, THEY WOULD HATE HIM.
THIS IS MY PREDICTION.
SOME EULER REPORT RELEASED ON
THURSDAY AT THE SAME PEOPLE WHO
HAVE LIED ALL ALONG WILL
FIND SOMETHING, ANYTHING IN THE
REPORT TO BLUDGEON THE PRESIDENT
AND BY THE WAY IT WILL NOT WORK
AGAIN BUT MANY ON THE LEFT ARE
SPECULATING THAT THE 30 PLUS
HOURS OF TESTIMONY FROM FORMER
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL DON McCANN
WILL BE THE LINCHPIN PROVIDING
DAMNING EVIDENCE OF WRONGDOING.
OKAY, LET'S DO SOMETHING THE
MEDIA MOB WON'T DO.
LET'S TAKE AN HONEST LOOK AT
TRUTH AND FACTS.
WE KNOW FOR A FACT OFFICIAL
COUNCIL FOUND NO RUSSIAN
COLLUSION BETWEEN TRUMP OR
ANYONE IN HIS CAMPAIGN.
MATTER OF FACT, WE HAVE THE
QUOTE FROM THE MUELLER REPORT.
THIS IS THE MUELLER REPORTS FROM
INVESTIGATION DID NOT ESTABLISH
THAT MEMBERS OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN -- CAMPAIGN CONSPIRED
OR COORDINATED WITH THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT AND ITS ELECTION INTR
GOVERNMENT AND ITS ELECTION INTE
GOVERNMENT AND ITS ELECTION INTC
ACTIVITIES.
NO COLLUSION.
WE ALSO KNOW FOR A FACT THREE
PREVIOUS INVESTIGATIONS ALSO
CLEARED THE PRESIDENT.
WHEN IT COMES TO CLAIMS THAT THE
PRESIDENT OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE, WE
ALSO KNOW FOR A FACT MUELLER DID
NOT CHARGE THE PRESIDENT WITH
OBSTRUCTION AND WE KNOW THAT
WILLIAM BARR, ROSENSTEIN, OFFICE
OF LEGAL COUNSEL AND YES, IN
CONJUNCTION WITH TALKING WITH
THE MUELLER TEAM CLEAR THE
PRESIDENT OF MANY CHARGES.
THE FACT THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
DID NOT FIRE MUELLER.
THEY WILL SAY HE WANTED TO FIRE
HIM, BUT HE DIDN'T.
HE DIDN'T SAY YOU WANTED TO FIRE
ROD ROSENSTEIN AND JEFF SESSIONS
BUT HE DIDN'T.
HE DIDN'T IMPEDE ANY
INVESTIGATION ANYWHERE.
HE DIDN'T INTERFERE WITH GENERAL
PLANS CASE OTHER THAN WISHING HE
DIDN'T GET IN TROUBLE AND HE DID
GET IN TROUBLE.
AS JAMES COMEY SAID THE
PRESIDENT HAS A RIGHT TO FIRE
HIM FOR ANY REASON OR NO REASON
AT ALL.
TO THE PRESIDENT TO TALK ABOUT
THESE THINGS, YEP ENTITY TALK
ABOUT THEM A LOT?
YEP.
THE DEMOCRATS ON HIS TEAM FIRING
ROSENSTEIN AND HOPING THE
GENERAL PLAN, A 33 YEAR MILITARY
WOULD NOT GET HURT, THEY
TALKED AN AWFUL LOT ABOUT
THINGS TOO LIKE WEARING A WIRE
TO SPRY ON THE PRESIDENT AND
INVOK THE 25TH AMENDMENT TO
REMOVE DULY ELECTED PRESIDENT.
THEY DIDN'T DO IT BUT THEY
TALKED ABOUT IT A LOT.
SO IF A PRESIDENT EXPRESSES
FRUSTRATION JUST LIKE THOSE FBI
DOJ GUYS ABOUT BEING
INVESTIGATED OR THEM NOT GETTING
THEIR POLITICAL WEIGHT OVER A
SERIOUS CRIMES THAT THEY DIDN'T
COMMIT IT'S NOT OBSTRUCTION.
ALSO NO INTENT.
VERY IMPORTANT AS IT RELATES TO
THE WALL CALLING OUT THE
CAMPAIGN DEMOCRATS THAT MUELLER
SAID TO PROBE THIS WHOLE THING.
THAT IS NOT OBSTRUCTION.
FRANKLY, THAT WAS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST FIRING JAMES
COMEY NOT OBSTRUCTION.
BY THE WAY, THE GOOD NEWS
PRESIDENT TRUMP SUMMED IT UP
PERFECTLY WHEN HE TWEETED OUT
EULER, THE AG BASED ON MUELLER
FINDINGS AND GREATER
INTELLIGENCE NO COLLUSION,
NO OBSTRUCTION, THESE CRIMES
WERE COMMITTED BY CRICKET
HILLARY, THE DNC, DIRTY COPS AND
OTHERS.
AND INVESTIGATE THE
INVESTIGATORS WHICH WE HAVE BEEN
DOING.
THE TABLES HAVE TURNED AND THEIR
LAST RUBBER BULLET.
IT WILL HIT, FOLD TO THE GROUND
AND IT'S ALL OVER.
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" WILL SMART
GUY CALLING FOR GRAND JURY AND
HIS RIGHT TO INVESTIGATE BAD
ACTORS IN THE DEEP STATE AND
ABUSE POWER.
IF THE FEDERAL BUREAU OF
INVESTIGATION TO RECOVER ITS
REPUTATION BUT I -- UPPER
ECHELON, THE FIRST ITEM ON
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR'S AGENDA
TO MAKE GOOD ON SOMETHING, THAT
SET OFF A FRENZY TO PROPOSE LAST
WEEK.
AND THE COUNTY OF THE FBI'S
BUYING COMMITTEE ASKED WITH A
SPITE ON TRUMP.
THEY DID.
MANY TIMES, MANY WAYS AND THAT
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS A VOW TO
ESTABLISH TEAM, TO INVESTIGATE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SPYING ON
THE CAMPAIGN, GREAT ARTICLE BY
ANDREW McCARTHY TO JOIN US IN
A FEW MINUTES DETAILING SOME OF
POTENTIALLY ILLICIT SURVEILLANCE
RATING LESS THAN A YEAR AGO THEO
RATING LESS THAN A YEAR AGO THEA
ADMINISTRATION WITH A
CONTROVERSIAL -- TO APPROACH THR
CONTROVERSIAL -- TO APPROACH THE
CONTROVERSIAL -- TO APPROACH THT
CONTROVERSIAL -- TO APPROACH THU
CONTROVERSIAL -- TO APPROACH THP
CONTROVERSIAL -- TO APPROACH THC
CONTROVERSIAL -- TO APPROACH THM
CONTROVERSIAL -- TO APPROACH THA
CONTROVERSIAL -- TO APPROACH THG
CONTROVERSIAL -- TO APPROACH TH'
CONTROVERSIAL -- TO APPROACH THS
WAITING TO THE 2016 ELECTION,
TRYING TO FIND PROOF THAT
CAMPAIGN COMPLICIT IN THE
CRIMINAL ONES HACKING OF
DEMOCRATS EMAIL.
ANDY McCARTHY TO CARTER PAGE,
PAPADOPOULOS AND SAM APPROACH BY
THE NAME OF STEPHAN HELP HER.
ONLY THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG.
THE TRUMP CARTER PAGE ALSO
ELECTRONICALLY SURVEILLED AND BY
THE WAY CAN SOMEONE TEACH CALL
ME WHAT THAT MEANS AFTER JAMES
COMEY SIGNED OFF ON THAT
APPLICATION.
THE BULK OF THE APPLICATION
FROM, AND VERIFIABLE AND
COOPERATED DIRTY RUSSIAN DOSSIER
PAID FOR BY HILLARY CLINTON.
LET'S NOT FORGET ABOUT THE 350%
INCREASE IN UNMASKING REQUESTS
BY OBAMA OFFICIALS IN THE
ELECTION YEAR 2016.
WHAT DID OBAMA KNOW?
WHEN DID HE KNOW IT?
BY THE WAY PETER STRZOK AND
PAGE, WHEN DID LETTER -- IN
BRANDON, CLAPPER, CREEPY UNCLE
JOE WHAT DID THEY KNOW AND WHEN
DID THEY KNOW IT?
WE WILL HAVE THE ANSWERS TO
THESE IMPORTANT QUESTIONS IN A
LETTER TO THE DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE,
CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN, HAVE
REQUESTED THAT 53.
WE ONLY HAVE LIKE SEVEN BUT 53
CLOSE DOOR TO TESTIMONY
TRANSCRIPTS BE MADE PUBLIC.
I'M SURE JERRY NADLER WILL JOIN
THEM BECAUSE HE DIDN'T WANT THE
RELEASE OF THE STARR REPORT.
AND ALREADY RECEIVED THROUGH
SORELY, PETER STRZOK, JAMES
BAKER AND FBI AND DOJ OFFICIALS
INVOLVED IN THE WITCH HUNT AND
IT WAS AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
THE FREE PASS GIVEN OF COURSE,
THEY LITERALLY GIVE A GET OUT OF
PARIS JAIL CARD BECAUSE THEY
LIKE HILLARY.
THE GUY THAT INTERVIEWED PETER
STRZOK COMMISSION WENT 100 TO
ZERO.
WE HAVE BEEN CLASSIFIED MATERIAL
THAT WAS FOUND ON UNSECURED
PRIVATE SERVER THAT WAS MANAGED
BY NETWORKS.
IT WAS IN A BATHROOM CLOSET.
SHE COMMITTED A REAL CRIME.
AND FOR US HAD A REAL INTENT TO
OBSTRUCT JUSTICE BY DESTROYING T
OBSTRUCT JUSTICE BY DESTROYING E
OBSTRUCT JUSTICE BY DESTROYING I
OBSTRUCT JUSTICE BY DESTROYING C
OBSTRUCT JUSTICE BY DESTROYING E
OBSTRUCT JUSTICE BY DESTROYING O
OBSTRUCT JUSTICE BY DESTROYING F
OBSTRUCT JUSTICE BY DESTROYING T
OBSTRUCT JUSTICE BY DESTROYING A
OBSTRUCT JUSTICE BY DESTROYING C
OBSTRUCT JUSTICE BY DESTROYING I
OBSTRUCT JUSTICE BY DESTROYING E
OBSTRUCT JUSTICE BY DESTROYING .
HENCE, 33,000 DELETED ACID
WASHED EMAILS.
THE MEDIA ON THURSDAY WILL
PRETEND TO CARE ABOUT
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
MEANWHILE, LITHIUM WILL IGNORE
THE BIGGEST SLAM-DUNK OF
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE CASE,
THAT IS RIGHT HILLARY'S CASE.
DEMOCRATS, THEY BELIEVE ALL THE
CAVANAUGH THE KUIPER -- A
KUIPER -- ACCUSERS, DEAFENING
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR, HE HAS BEEN
ACCUSED OF RATE AND VIOLENT
SEXUAL ASSAULT SO WHERE ARE
ALL THE EYE BELIEVERS?
OBSTRUCTION MATTERS BUT ONLY IF
IT IS TRUMP, NOT
HILLARY CLINTON.
CHARGES OF RATE SERIOUS
SEXUAL ASSAULT, ONLY MATTERS IF
APPOINTED BY TRUMP BUT NOT THE
DEMOCRATIC LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR OF VIRGINIA.
A CLEAR, VIOLATION OF THE
ESPIONAGE ACT, 18 U.S. 793, THE
LAW BY HILLARY CLEARED BECAUSE
THE INVESTIGATION WAS RIGGED.
WHY DID JAMES COMEY OBSTRUCT IN
WRITING EXONERATION WITH JULY?
WHY DID THEY TAKE OUT GROSS
NEGLIGENCE THE LEGAL STANDARD
AND EXTREME CARELESSNESS?
WHY DID PETRUS TRICKLE ALLOW TWO
PEOPLE IN THE INTERVIEW ROOM
WHEN HE WAS INTERVIEWING ON JULN
WHEN HE WAS INTERVIEWING ON JUL,
WHEN HE WAS INTERVIEWING ON JUL2
WHEN HE WAS INTERVIEWING ON JUL1
WHEN HE WAS INTERVIEWING ON JUL"
WHEN HE WAS INTERVIEWING ON JULJ
WHEN HE WAS INTERVIEWING ON JULM
WHEN HE WAS INTERVIEWING ON JULS
WHEN HE WAS INTERVIEWING ON JULC
WHEN HE WAS INTERVIEWING ON JULM
WHEN HE WAS INTERVIEWING ON JULY
WHEN HE WAS INTERVIEWING ON JULO
WHEN HE WAS INTERVIEWING ON JULN
JULY 5TH?
HE WRITTEN THAT MAYOR AND WHAT
DID BILL CLINTON AND
LORETTA LYNCH TALK ABOUT THE
SECRET MEETING ON THE TARMAC IN
PHOENIX BEFORE HILLARY WAS
CLEARED?
LYNCH, THE FBI IN CONCERT
TOGETHER TO CLEAR THE CLINTONS?
DID THEY BREAK THAT
INVESTIGATION OBVIOUS SHE
COMMITTED FELONIES BECAUSE SHE
IS THE ONE TO WIN 100,000,020?
NOTHING BUT SMELLY WALMART
VOTERS.
AND HILLARY CLINTON RIGGED AND
SPYING ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN TO
COMMITTING A FRAUD AND PFIZER
ABUSE TO UNMASKING AMERICAN
CITIZENS OF ABUSING POWERFUL
TOOLS OF EVERYTHING IN BETWEEN.
WE WILL NOW FINALLY GET THE
ANSWERS.
THE MEDIA WON'T GO THERE.
THEY WILL HAVE TO ADMIT THEY ARE
WRONG.
THEY WON'T APOLOGIZE.
THEY WON'T RETRACT.
THEY WON'T SAY, JEEZ, CAVANAUGH
GOT IT RIGHT.
DON'T HOLD YOUR BREATH.
WE WILL HAVE A LOT MORE
THROUGHOUT THE SHOW BUT FIRST,
WE MUST REPORT ON HANNITY WATCH
AND THE RADICAL SOCIALIST, 2020
DEMOCRATS FROM A VERY REVEALING
WEEK FOR THE FAR LEFT TRYING TO
BECOME PRESIDENT.
WE START WITH THE CURRENT MAYOR
OF SOUTH BEND, INDIANA, YES,
THAT GUY MAY REPEAT.
PETER BUDDHA COULD WHO SAID THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGES ONE BIG
MANIPULATION OF THE SYSTEM.
OKAY, WATCH THIS.
>> IF YOU REALIZE THIS IS A FAIR
PLACE FOR EVERYONE'S VOTE COUNT
AT THE SAME.
THE DEPICT OUR PRESIDENT TO
TALLY THE VOTES AND GIVE IT TO
THE PERSON WHO GOT THE MOST